le ferroviaire au coeur du plan de
relance du gouvernement près de 5
milliards d'euros de ce plan iront à la
sncf le train fait son grand retour à la
faveur de la transition énergétique
il se pose comme une alternative à l'est
rien et au transport routier
mais les défis sont nombreux ouverture à
la concurrence gestion de la préco vide
au final l'entreprise publique est elle
vraiment la grande gagnante de ce plan
on obtient un tel qu'un répit on en
parle tout de suite avec l'économiste
jacques sapir bienvenue jeanne bonsoir à
vous
bonsoir c'est fanny alors jacques
comment se présente l'avenir de la sncf
qui semble plutôt avantager un par ce
plan de relance présenté au début du
mois oui indiscutablement avec 4,7
milliards pour la sncf présent dans le
plan de relance c'est une bonne nouvelle
il faut ajouter à cela évidemment que le
gouvernement a présenté une forme de
deux plans de relance de plans de
priorité pour le transport ferroviaire
il voudrait justement substituer le
train à certain nombre de voyages en
avion relancer le fret relancer les tran
huy dont tout ça on apparences ce sont
d'excellentes nouvelles sauf que
malheureusement la sncf sort du
confinement et avant de la grève qu'il y
avait eu fin 2019 début 2020 assez
affaibli et on peut se demander si elle
pourra justement profiter de cette
situation qui devrait lui être pourtant
favorable alors que représente jacques
le volet transports au sein de la partie
transition écologique des plans de
relance alors il faut savoir que dont le
plan de relance il ya grosso modo 30
milliards d'euros qui sont destinées si
vous voulez à la transition écologique
sur ces 30 milliards il y en a 11
milliards qui sont destinés aux
problèmes des transports et sur ces 11
milliards justement on a les 4,7
milliards pour la sncf
alors ça semble effectivement important
et d'une certaine manière c'est d'autant
plus important que le gouvernement avant
la crise de lakovic 19 et indien a
repris à sa charge une grosse partie de
la dette de la sncf
fin 2010
f la dette de la sncf s'était 60
milliards d'euros dont 52 milliards rien
que pour le réseau est là le
gouvernement
il a repris 22 milliards donc on se dit
voilà c'est un effort qui est quand même
un effort extrêmement important oui mais
quand on regarde ce que pèsent ces 4,7
milliards surtout déjà à côté des 22
milliards qui ont été décidé bien avant
la crise de lakovic 19 et bien on peut
se dire que malgré tout il ya peut-être
une certaine ambiguïté dans la force de
ce plan alors j'avais dit que ces
difficultés se sont plutôt aggravées
avec le confinement oui tout à fait pour
le premier semestre de 2020 si l'on
regarde les comptes de la sncf on voit
que la sncf a perdu à peu près deux
milliards 4 ce qui est nettement plus
que ce qu'elle avait perdu dans la même
époque en 2019
ce qui veut dire que on va se retrouver
avec 4 milliards peut être 4 milliards 5
de déficit à la fin de l'année à 4900 de
déficit c'est pratiquement la somme qui
est prévu dans le plan si vous voulez
dans le plan de relance
la somme qui est prévu dans le plan de
relance c'est 4 7 milliards et puis un
autre problème
on constate aussi toujours si on regarde
les comptes de la sncf que les
investissements ont baissé or la sncf
elle a dramatiquement besoin aujourd'hui
d'investir
alors de quel ordre justement ces
investissements alors ces
investissements on peut les mettre dans
trois directions
tout d'abord évidemment si le
gouvernement veut que la sncf remplace
le train pour des voyages de ville en
vivre exemple sur paris toulouse paris
bordeaux
bon il va devoir investir va devoir
investir en matériel va falloir plus de
rames de tgv va aussi falloir investir
dans le réseau il va falloir investir
dans le système de signalisation dans
les caténaires
rappelez-vous l'épisode un petit peu
dramatique où des gens qui venaient
d'hendaye ont été en tgv ont été bloqués
ils ont mis plus de 20 heures pour
revenir sur paris
bref si on veut vraiment assurer la
ponctualité la rapide
it et de ses transports oui il faudra
investir ça c'est une évidence deuxième
point c'est le développement des lignes
secondaires alors là aussi si on veut
développer les lignes secondaires il va
falloir racheter du matériel
il va falloir des ter qui soit nettement
plus fréquents bien sûr les régions
prennent leur charge dans ses dépenses
mais il faudra de manière absolument
évidente que l'état apporte je dirais ça
pierre est une pierre plutôt importante
dans ce secteur
et puis on a le problème de la relance
des trains de nuit et de la relance du
fret ferroviaire alors bon deux
excellentes nouvelles mais il faut
savoir que les trains de nuit gars n'a
pratiquement plus donc ça veut dire que
si on veut vraiment relancer les trains
de nuit il faudra racheter massivement
du matériel il faudra de nouveaux
équipements
même chose pour le fret parce que si
vous voulez la question du fret c'est
bien beau de dire qu'il faut développer
le fret ferroviaire
mais l'essentiel c'est comment on fait
passer des charges du camion au train et
puis après du train aux camions ce qu'on
appelle le transport multimodal et là
encore ça va demander des
investissements extrêmement lourd or
vous vous posez la question jacques ça
va coûter combien
alors si on consulte différents
instituts ou différents bureaux d'études
qui ont travaillé là dessus on aboutit à
une espèce de consensus et a dit qu'il
faudrait entre 15 et 20 milliards
d'investissements en plus des
investissements qui sont déjà prévues
pour les prochaines années
pas d'investissement global c'est
vraiment de l'investissement
supplémentaire d'ici cinq ans alors mais
vous dites aussi qu'il y à un
l'ouverture à la concurrence n'est ce
pas oui tout à fait et ça il faut le
savoir c'est que à partir de la fin de
l'ensemble du réseau ferroviaire sera
justement ouvert à la concurrence alors
cette ouverture à la concurrence
justement elle a déjà eu lieu dans le
domaine du frais et c'est un petit peu
ça qui en réalité a tué le fret avec la
suppression de toute une série de lignes
donc oui la concurrence ça va reposer un
problème extrêmement important à la sncf
et pourquoi
alors est tout d'abord à partir du
moment où il ya concurrence est bien
évidemment les concurrents donc les
différentes sociétés qui vont assurer le
transport ferroviaire
elles vont se précipiter sur les lignes
les plus rentables et elles vont
abandonner justement les rings les
lignes qui ne sont pas rentables
or il faut savoir que le transport
ferroviaire
c'est un transport en réseau et donc si
on veut que les gens prennent le tgv
plutôt qu'ils ne prennent la voiture
eh bien il va falloir leur assurer le
transport du premier kilomètre au
dernier kilomètre
autrement dit ça veut dire qu'il faudra
bien sûr qu'il y ait les lignes de tgv
mais il faudra qu'il y ait des
correspondances sur des lignes de ter
qui les amène justement leur destination
le problème du transport c'est que on
voit bien que c'est justement cette
épaisse de continuité du premier au
dernier kilomètre qui compte
si un opérateur de transport n'est pas
capable de fournir justement cette
espèce de continuité d'assurer les
correspondances
s'il n'en est pas capable et bien à ce
moment là les gens choisiront la voiture
est ce que l'on constate et on l'a
constaté dans plusieurs pays
c'est que la concurrence s'est très
souvent la voie la plus rapide à la
privatisation et c'est souvent la voie
la plus rapide au retour de la voiture
comme moyen de transport
ouais donc jeanne vous pensez que la
sncf sera comme vous dites
le dindon de la farce alors je pense
qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire mais on
peut avoir
on peut garder ce risque à l'esprit
parce que si vous voulez derrière cette
ouverture à la concurrence ya la
privatisation
on sait très bien que l'union européenne
poussent à la privatisation injustement
et de la sncf et de l'ensemble des
opérateurs ferroviaires
or il faut aussi savoir une chose c'est
que cette privatisation à cette
concurrence ça ne marche pas la grande
bretagne qui avait été promis pionnière
justement dans le domaine de la
privatisation du secteur ferroviaire
eh bien elle est revenue là dessus les
britanniques ont renationaliser
l'ensemble des sociétés qui s'occupent
du transport ferroviaire donc oui on a
ce problème et globalement on
se demander s'il y a bien une cohérence
entre les objectifs qui ont été fixés
par le gouvernement
objectifs qui sont tout à fait
respectable tout à fait défendable par
ailleurs et les moyens 1 qu'il met
justement pour qu'on atteigne ses
objectifs
autrement dit donnera-t-on réellement à
la sncf les moyens financiers pour
qu'elle puisse remplir ses objectifs et
la question reste heures en suspens on
verra la réponse merci jacques d'avoir
été on dirait